le parlement européen et l'union
africaine parlent d'une même voix et
s'inquiète de la prise de pouvoir des
militaires aux tchadiens depuis la mort
du président idriss deby itno
les députés européens appellent ainsi à
des élections plus vite
l'ua exige une transition démocratique
en 18 mois le conseil de paix et de
sécurité de l'union africaine souligne
la nécessité absolue que la transition
vers un régime démocratique soit achevée
dans le délai de 18 mois annoncé par le
conseil militaire de transition à
compter du 20 avril 2021
le conseil de paix et de sécurité
demande aussi au président et aux
membres du conseil militaire de
transition de respecter l'engagement
qu'ils ont pris de ne pas se présenter
ou de ne pas prendre part aux prochaines
élections libres justes et crédibles à
la fin de la période de transition
elle peut en parler aussi en direct avec
mac est longue et bla journalistes
blogueurs et spécialiste des tchats
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors les députés
européens qui appelle à un retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel
quelle est la valeur de cet appel et
pourquoi serait-il entendu plus qu'un
autre d'abord je tiens à remercier le
député européen et pour avoir voté cette
résolution condamnant à l'unanimité à
leroy va au parlement européen
l'indien mittal qui a confisqué le
pouvoir notamment les besoins de l'étude
du plan d'eli manning débit en tout en
estimant que c'est un pas important et
ne pas fort notamment rompt pas
également des gels des avoirs
définit-elle de l'egypte c'est à dire
les membres du comité du conseil it et
les tensions ne pouvant pas ce qu'il a
en toute liberté et on regarde
effectivement à des la majorité des
députés qui ont voté à 635 27
d donc 50 notamment les valeurs de
l'europe fournée du jour et j'espère
qu'ils les différents pays de tout leur
poids dans le cadre de la coopération
avec les dates et jia style la geste du
sort ne puisse pas quand même être ne
puisse pas non plus quand même respecter
cet engagement et ses dépositions
mais justement ce genre de résolution
qui a été adoptée par les députés
européens est ce que c'est suffisant
pour que les militaires tchadiens quitte
le pouvoir dans quelques mois
mais tout dépend évidemment des actions
qui seront menées auprès auprès de
l'europe est prêt même des partenaires
tchadien et notamment les cannes et dans
la résolution qui nous avaient très bien
les députés en exil ainsi qu'est le chat
coopère avec d'une européenne et vous
savez ligue européenne et pour compléter
contributif et ce tous les attributs
rodez le point des rocs de l'europe
envers l'état sont des malades d'une
importante capitale et qui vont
peut-être peser sur les négociations et
a amené les la junte militaire au
pouvoir de pouvoir céder aux exigences
de l'europe
nous pensons également que cet exemple
attaquer les orphelins à l'égard du
cadran qui ne respecte pas ses
engagements internationaux vis-à-vis des
secteurs notamment les européens il est
doté d'un corps en général
alors on vient de parler des députés
européens ya également cette résolution
de l'union africaine est-ce que c'est
pas arrivé un peu trop tard pourquoi n'y
at il pas eu au sein de l'union
africaine de consensus avant nous avons
toujours dit madame que l'union
africaine coléreux d'y rester fidèle à
ses engagements
et justement elle devient du délire
africain devient trop tard
ac il a fallu que l'union européenne
d'une manière unanime printemps de la
junte militaire au poids et une lueur
africaine de conseils persie côté face
un retour peu dommage pour revenir sur
sa décision et xviiie rask et là alors
le moteur à leur conscience a fabriqué
une note ken qui avait déjà envoyé une
mission sur place en dominant qui avait
édité un rapport à ses engagements
internationaux la vie roumanie elle a
même imposé des sanctions et des
embargos l'état d'esprit du cadenas
un peu ça qu'il n'était pas quand même
comprendre avec leurs engagements de
toutes les manières
l'union européenne vient de confirmer
les disciples du sud et étudiants parce
que l'équipe est bien à sa mobilité et
qu'avant avec ce type qui vient enfin
condamne la junte militaire au pouvoir
est donc vraiment cet acte nous a
soulagés nous avons vraiment le
conforter dans notre engagement et de
leur détermination à lutter contre
effectivement la confiscation du pouvoir
et surtout le mode de vie ne se démode
de transition démocratique du pouvoir au
tchad alors on a deux appels insistants
aujourd'hui on a six de l'union
africaine issue du parlement européen
selon vous est-ce que ces deux instances
ont vraiment une marche de manoeuvre sur
les militaires tchadiens forcément un
sith édition normalement un emballement
aline africaine qui devrait prendre les
choses en main sauf qu'il n'ya qu'elle
s'est dit et ses conseillers contre
elle-même est maintenant l'union
européenne a fait les choses en main et
nous pensons également qu'il va vers une
convergence de points de vue entre les
députés européens et la commission et la
commission précipité de devenir africain
tout effectivement les décisions qui
sont dans un cadre de partenaires
puissent quand même failli de manière
unanime est imposé à ce qu'est la junte
vite vous racontez pas d'inventer pas du
tout d'un coup tout leur effectif
la prise du pouvoir par les entretiens
qui est de l'autre côté une année un peu
partout au mali
et c'est pourquoi nous appelons
effectivement à toutes ces décisions à
plus d'harmonie dans les réactions
comines s'allier afin d'amener je pense
que renvoyer ce serait un précédent
fâcheux aussi bien pour nos pays aussi
bien pour la collectivité c'est des
siens qui sont venus avec un dîner aux
fans qui ont vraiment fait qu'ils sont
effectivement devenus aujourd'hui la
situation de toutes et tous les regards
de l'opinion publique tchadienne alors
l'union africaine un fixe donc un délai
de 18 mois pour la transition à
démocratique on va faire un bond dans le
futur si dans 18 mois le cnt ne qui
parle le pouvoir au tchad que fera
l'union africaine nous avons su nous
avons demandé à l'inaf qui n'est pas
d'elle mais tu as un gène d'éternuements
nous aurait exigé ce qu'ils ignorent
africaine fasse en sorte que la gêne qui
plaît pour alexis
déjà une transition aujourd'hui les
musulmans sont lents pour leurs peuples
le peuple tchadien et dans la rue vous
savez depuis pratiquement un mois deux
mois au pouvoir le peuple tchadien et
dans la nuit à une telle puissance
sauvage et d'impression avec 10 points
concernés malheureusement madame de
signer ici l'attitude de l'ambassadeur
de france au tchad mais si beretta
gaucher ricky qui disent les militants
policière de l'aspect civil de ne pas
manifester et qui positionne le voir
enfin nous pensons également que l'union
africaine doit avoir des mesures
coercitives est un peu faire à l'égard
de la junte au pouvoir on ne peut pas
d'un côté du quai le capot bien l'armé
canal et en mai puis contre toulouse
alors que cette même armée les pousse à
peu semblant population souvent des
billets sous son fils de don il ya deux
ans vivant si c'est pourquoi dans la
région du nord afin de rendre
l'internaute constater qu'il n'en
reprenne salue lundi dans les dynamiques
peuvent rien qui dans la rue et qui
milite de manière pacifique il faut
seulement qu'il de gestion fasse en
sorte qu'ils aient les condamnations
sont des condamnations fermes à l'égard
des drm mito fois il faut absolument que
l'âge est quitte le pouvoir et qu'un
institut du jeu c'est en cette période
france le territoire des dix-huit mois
s'il faut mais sans cela je pense
qu'elles peuvent très bien voir dans la
rue et l'association respire est d'être
toujours cristallisé entre le pouvoir
illégitime et la rue qui écrit comme de
la démocratie de la justice sociale et
surtout de l'alternance pacifique dans
ces pays là encore il appartient à lille
à l'union africaine surtout d'effets
spéciaux et de respecter elle même ses
engagements vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
et notamment de ses membres dont le
châtiment
je pense qu'effectivement que nous
sommes là et nous allons continuer à
vivre et à faire en sorte que les
résolutions des mineurs faire puisque
même avoir un impact fort aussi bien
sonnés par terre sur le chat et les
autres partenaires notamment la france
et nous appelons également à respecter
l'addition de départ est monté de 20 qui
sont quand même majoritaire makaila
niebla merci d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journalistes
blogueurs et spécialiste du tchad merci
à vous